bonjour cc fio pour brut les questions
qui sont souvent revenus
comment expliquez-vous la violence dans
le rap considérer que les rappeurs sont
simplement des sondés les responsables
de tous les maux de la société c'est une
erreur au bout d'un moment la violence
on la vit forcément à se reflète à
travers ce qu'on vit à ça à travers ce
qu'on essaie pas parfois il ya des
personnes qui ont des éditions des
aigles est un petit peu violent mais qui
sont liées à leur mode de vie
mais pour eux ce n'est pas violent pour
eux c'est leur éducation
c'est leur quotidien c'est leur vie
c'est de la manière dont ils ont grandi
finalement tout compte fait à
l'impression en fait que le violent
c'est quoi c'est de dire ce que tu vis
mais non ce que tu vis c'est ça qui est
beau la violence final c'est on vit
culte et violence et spiritueux tata 6
mai au quotidien c'est la compression
social c'est tout ça qui s'est tous tous
ces choses là qui sont violentes
mais paradoxalement à tout ça ce qui est
intéressant c'est que là tu pour moi la
critique le mépris la médisance et est
une forme de violence ces gens là ils
disent des choses qui sont liées à ce
qu'ils pensent sans se rendre compte de
l'impact que cela peut avoir son nom
comment on arrive on nous a assez à ses
stigmates
comment on arrive on nous a à avoir des
paroles aussi virulente et aussi
violente
comment on arrive on nous la commet
posez vous la question
vous voulez dire quoi par ça en gros ce
qui me viennent un petit peu c'est qu'on
libéralise un petit peu trop le rap
par moments on a trop tendance à vouloir
tout comprendre alors qu'on n'a pas
forcé on n'est pas forcément obligé de
tout comprendre
il ya pas mal dargaud il ya pas mal
d'expression qui nous sont
à proprement dit appropriée des choses
qui viennent du langage de quartier
n'est pas qu'on n'a pas besoin forcément
de comprendre tu vas aimer le problème
c'est que le rap il est jugé par d'élite
r&d littéraire des écrivains comme dans
certaines émissions tu vois et on a
tendance à regarder au compte gouttes
tout ce qu'on raconte alors que parfois
il ya derrière de l'argot il ya des mots
qui conte avant ta joie qui qui sont
véhiculées dans nos textes et puis il
faut savoir si tu n'est en fait sans
forcément chercher plus loin je dirais
qu'il ya déjà des partis pour moi il ya
dans autant dans les quartiers parfois
on fait un peu la surenchère de beaucoup
de choses mais autant si on va dire
qu'on est face à une à des gens qui sont
très très frileux des des personnes qui
ne connaissent pas un petit peu la vie
de quartier qui ont beaucoup
d'appréhension par rapport à parce qu'on
est et ce qu'on véhicule
mais encore encore une fois encore une
fois de plus si la mentalité qui existe
dans dans ce pays cette mentalité ou en
bon juge selon l'accoutrement et non pas
selon le fonds selon ce que les gens
sont réellement donc on juge uniquement
qu'à travers ce que tu peux représenter
d'un point de vue du faciès d'un point
de vue des codes vestimentaires etc et
vous conscience que vous faites du rap
politique considérant que quand on parle
de choses de problèmes sociétaux bas ça
concerne forcément ça va dans la case de
la politique et ça c'est on va dire une
question qui m'a souvent été posée qui
m'a énormément déranger vivre le
quotidien dans un quartier et en parler
c'est pas forcément parler de politique
les politiciens s'en servent pour
alimenter des programmes et pour les
argumenter à travers des campagnes mais
on les vit en fait ces choses là donc je
comprends j'ai jamais compris pourquoi
on fait parler de choses qui concerne
les quartiers des problèmes de d'équité
des problèmes de parité va ça allait
forcément dans la case de la politique
donc pour moi c'est vivre ce qu'on vit
tout simplement sans forcément sans
forcément plus pourquoi avez-vous fait
le choix d'avoir d'avoir opté pour la
musique et non pas pour le football
je pense qu'on a toujours tendance à
croire que dans les quartiers on a
uniquement des qualités qui sont liées à
ce qu'on fait avec les mains ou ce qu'on
peut faire avec les pieds tu vois qu'on
ne pense pas assez qu'on a en fait une
motricité qui n'est pas du tout on va
dire en adéquation avec la moyenne en
fait comme si on était un petit peu en
dessous et c'est un petit peu voilà
c'est tous les vecteurs que tu peut
véhiculer les quartiers voiture à tous
les clichés les stigmates
si c'est vrai qu'à travers on va dire ce
qui reflète ma personnalité c'est
souvent le fait que j'avais entre
parenthèses une carrière de footballeur
qui s'ouvre à moi mais souvent si une
question un petit peu qu'ils revenaient
qui avait des airs de clichés on va dire
cliché un petit peu du mec qui avait pas
qui n'a pas pu être un footballeur
professionnel et qui est devenu un
rappeur donc voilà